President Trump very angry because
people are speculating I could just
start there he's angry why would I need
yeah why would I need to say more than
that
that guy is perpetually angry about
something yeah look sit talk sit well
president Trump is now angry that people
were speculating on the whereabouts of
Melania Trump furious about it today on
Twitter president Trump denied rumors
that his wife Melania got a facelift who
denied it yeah Trump said trust me when
my wife needs a new face I'll get a new
wife
it's hard to do a Trump I just got a
haircut and it's popping up you know
what I mean it's we gotta lay down for
Trump you know keep a hunk of hair in
your pocket and / yeah that's what he
does
alright but is the big story though
Melania made her first appearance in
almost 27 days yeah Melania Trump's
first public appearance was with the
president at a briefing on preparing for
disasters drew the event took place in
the White House's metaphor room so I'd
have preferred laughter but I'll take
that see what he did yeah very nice
Parliament here and thank you wow this
is a weird one well he was on a call
with the Canadian Prime Minister
president Trump falsely accused Canada
was actually Britain but he falsely
accused Canada of burning down the White
House in the war of 1812 yeah yeah Trump
tried to patch things up by saying it's
okay we kicked your ass at Gettysburg so
it was just reported that 10 New Jersey
beaches have been found to have unsafe
levels of fecal bacteria
the good news all the other beaches in
New Jersey have safe amounts jump in
just die there a man in Florida was
arrested after he was caught with
several stolen zoo animals yeah yeah
would have gotten away with it too if
the parrot hadn't talked
thank you Wow of all of them the one
they liked the most was the one for
children and the pig squeals come on I
like that one too
welcome to our nickelodeon show we have
a great one for you tonight
you